володимир владимирович путін 1000 вин
називаючи power на ньому світлові можуть
насті росіяни
для у село святу дорученням норм
міжнародного права чим може santee
парку над цими людьми ну зміните свій курс
експерти змінить відпочинок ще санкції
за мало але активно грунтів на
дипломатично стратегія санкції не може
бути єдиним інструментом розумним якщо
творити та вигадувати для подалі
проговоривши до на вигляд новими контакті
або передачі можна гості виходу
як для тих, хто супроводжуючи санкції так
та для tedx проти кого ван з прямого не
випало не буде пов'язані з чіткими
політичними паперами
засовуйте санте треба про святе ливають
ще ви не можете про 3-го ти повинен
волосся і діти про так звана
стратегічної терпіння ось таких
вказуючи прокладку б одну були
шоковані завжди дістати вже пістолеті
США домагаються до спроби зміни режиму
за підмогою вже паростках висотного сантей
успіху на я ж по протещу куба
економічно подвійного на вч and іракського
диктатура саддама хусейна ми змогли
поставити на калина
адже з анти зусиль міжнародні спи
але ти про те числі їм баргу на продаж
авто обрання його режим стрибуни в
підставі 2000 витрачав уроку вище після
ризикового включаючи заходу санкція кіу
хвали вала в минулому мурада б заспівати
він малі зовсім не важенина зливки
цей крок став економічнішим за татарву в одні
санкції продуктивного сяду з коротше
не опцію до торгівлі
часто ванни відкривають силоміць новий
можливості причому а для тих кілт і ким
б зовсім не хотіла б то помади на
приклад і ранд у ту годину так носила не
то обривати не пить принципу 3 напувати
душа сувора ксанті близькі дорожимо у
клани про крим та диск за декретом не
економити це контрабанді та вартою
ісламської революції ще контролює
литого рахунку морські порти
таким чином збу давала собі державний
бізнес-імперію фактор ризику
ми по чому ще в ірані і вийти
знову продати їм західних інвесторів
а за місцем традиційних батарейних
економічні диски між європейськими
то іранськими фірмами іран почав
розвиватися економічністю проти
китайськими наступництво тисячу
економічні санкції задають skoda i
think the їх заправляти ж спочатку
зручно відома і володимиру путіну вин і
відкрито занурюючи за планети постачання
нафтогазу ще правда в такому разі
ціна була занадто висока вона для
сама прогула шини великі держави
руси та